en travaillant sur cette émission nous
nous sommes vite aperçus de la
complexité de l'ampleur de la tâche pour
les services alimentaires en milieu
hospitalier mais nous avons été
agréablement surpris parce qu'il ya un
virage qui est amorcé une véritable
révolution alimentaire
cette émission devrait vous être
présenté fin mars et coved oblige nous
ne l'avons pas fait alors toutes les
images que vous allez voir on été tourné
avant la pandémie
à la base ce qu'on souhaite c'est qu'ils
mangent
on y malade on a fait pareil à un moment
donné la jaune les repas servis aux
patients dans les hôpitaux ont souvent
mauvaise réputation peu savoureux beige
nous froid rien pour remonter le moral
quand nous sommes en convalescence on
jetait 25% des plateaux
donc il ya 25% des plateaux qui revenait
à la cuisine on les met à la poubelle
s'est documenté un patient avec un bon
état nutritionnel voir guérir beaucoup
plus rapidement
quelle que soit la maladie nous avons
visité cinq services alimentaires de
centre hospitalier de la région de
montréal et de halifax pour constater
comment le milieu hospitalier est passé
de la réflexion à l'action
je pense qu'il faut que l'alimentation
soit revue différentes
le consensus se fait sur la saveur il
faut que ce soit bon ces robots ce sont
des véhicules autoguidés qui
maintiennent à la bonne température et
livre les repas des patients depuis les
cuisines du deuxième sous sol jusqu'aux
étage des chambres du tout nouveau chum
ce super hôpital né du regroupement de
trois anciens hôpitaux universitaires de
la région de montréal a ouvert ses
portes en 2010 est en cours de
planification des services alimentaires
tout était à revoir traditionnellement
dans la plupart des hôpitaux
les repas sont choisis quelques jours à
l'avance est préparé en liaison froide
la liaison froide en fait c'est un que
les blés les mets sont produits à la
main sont refroidies et puis les mets
sont assemblés à froid non les plateaux
ce qui permet d'assembler des plateaux à
tout autre jour on peut face en dehors
des heures normales puis sert à terme
alizés par la suite dans des chariots
un des inconvénients de ce type de
service et le gaspillage
chaque usager reçoit un repas complet
alors que l'appétit n'est parfois pas au
rendez vous ce qui coûte cher c'est
faire des plats qui est loin de jeter ou
pendant g
ça ça coûte cher jean-marc riverains
dirige les services alimentaires pour le
cius centre sud de l'île de montréal est
encore revenu on s'organise pour que
nous a servi d manger et non pas de
nourrir et poubelles ou je ne sais trop
quoi son service alimentaire ser 6
millions de repas par année dans deux
hôpitaux 17 ch et celle des et des
centres jeunesse
on conçoit les menus pour tous et dans
toutes les conditions
je vous parle dans les deux trois
dernières années nous avons eu la
commande les plantes et un menu
harmoniser ce qu'on a fait à un rythme
accéléré on implantait deux centres
d'hébergement par trois semaines et là
on s'est mis à mesurer notre impact nos
résultats avec les comités de résidents
vous ont dit on aimerait ça vous faire
déguster trois nouvelles réserves
puisque tout changer c'est l'interaction
avec les usagers
[Musique]
chaque année monsieur arriverai réuni
une équipe de cuisiniers et
nutritionniste de divers établissements
du sus afin d'élaborer les nouveaux
menus développer des recettes et les
standardiser est ce que la sauce et les
pâtes ont déjà intégré les crevettes de
matane
aujourd'hui on va le faire et je vais
faire deux recettes distingue pour
évaluer la valeur nutritive pour savoir
ce que ça vaut la peine et quelle
quantité
les hommes de coin standardisation sands
est ce aussi s'assurer que la recette ou
qu'elle soit produite vers chelsea
tenait compte qu'elle cuisine on en
arrive au même résultat en termes de
qualité en termes de quantité donc entre
au delà sans datation de l'onu
permettent en toutes conditions partie
que ce soit dans arrivé il ya un an la
mesure doit donc j'avais la même recette
de sur place et certains jeux plus ou
moins claires à liège on chante c'est à
dire qui est là la soupe l'année et qu
est desservie dans mon retour référé la
liaison froide où est la différence au
bout du compte dans l'assiette station
ckoi même résultat mais mme blum et
matériaux pour les 2-6 ans quand on fait
un test c'est le première veut avoir un
produit qui est beau et bon nous on veut
manger qu'à nos collègues cafétéria
veulent manger
après on se penche sur les différentes
possibilités moi vous aimez
nous commettons tous le monde de
différence est pour vous
les gérants de la cuisine le félicite on
veut manger de la bouffe à l'hôpital
mais pas de la bouffe d'hôpital alors
cette année tu agis de légumes grillés
et à l'appareil pois chiche
avec cet apport de sucres simples à quoi
à peu près on était un riche en
protéines il est assez complet qu en
place et inspiré de coin s'est vraiment
produit qui sont autour et puis ça tombe
comme ça
l'équipe a goûté ses conclusions c'est
pour ça qu'on va l'envoyer au test
l'équipe de caroline jacques au chum a
opté pour une courroie de liaison chaude
c'est à dire que les plateaux sont
assemblés avec des plats chauds et
maintenus à bonne température jusqu'à la
livraison aux usagers avant c'était un
canevas de plateau plus défini avec une
soupe un plat principal un dessert on
voulait poursuivre quand même avec un
service est plus traditionnel où le
patient était prise en charge par la
technicienne en diététique puis où on
monte un menu plus adapté au passé à ses
goûts ses aversion donc lors on voit
plus modulé avec le patient
ce qu'on met dans le plateau la matière
première
ici on reçoit vraiment les aliments
breton et on les transforme ici on a les
deux pesé donc d'un côté on fait ce
qu'on appellerait
il est produit et de l'autre côté on
fasse tout ce qui les guide et ensuite
ça s'en va de longue portée qui s'est
transformé ici au chum on sert 2,6
millions de repas chaque année dont 1
million pour les patients sans fin vers
3500 patients à la cafétéria
on a aussi un volet traitant ici ocean
donc si on est votre premier le rapport
en moyenne vous savez si on parle de la
brigade vous avez combien devant environ
être excusés temps complet tous les
jours environ 5,6 à cuisiner et des
plongeurs ça fait partie un peu de
demandes que le cheminement des depuis
quelques années donc on décide
d'embaucher des chefs timan des gens
d'expérience donc on essaie de prendre
un peu qu'est ce que nous avons obtenu
est de les ramener ici avec les copains
budgétaire même si avec qu'est-ce que
banques pour un dépassement on essaye de
beaucoup de travailler avec des produits
chers tout qu'est-ce qu'on peut
travailler au niveau du gameplay des
abbés reich maintenant pour l'essai de
parfois m on fait beaucoup d'efforts
pour que ce soit vraiment bon regarde
c'est ça c'est un bel exemple de plock
on fait juste
on l'envoie directement fait qu on la
voit donc on y suit proche de la croix
la sandale où seront rassemblés
reproduit patients donc nous on a des
cuisines sont mandatés ici ils ont
vraiment là ils gardent l'entrée p6 avec
à l'arrivée une cuisson qui doit tout
faire pour aider justement avec cette
notion que la nourriture du bétail n'est
pas bonne bonjour c'est ma terre va bien
à l'inversé
bonjour je m'appelle fans je suis avec
thierry qui est le chef qui vous a
préparé on essaie d'avoir de plus en
plus le pouls de la clientèle
côté services à la carte des tout c'est
surprenant pour un obstacle
on remarque que depuis qu'on met les
mets que le patient désagréments à
meilhan et - perte est gamin tu nous
aurons notre avis ou de nouvelles
recettes ce faisant il y avait le
dernier mot
la nourriture total on salue le
maintient de l'étape et bonjour les
temps j'ai la chance
ce serait pour elle a chanté en trois
étapes le bronze à quel nom annabelle
donc j'apprends la carité lancé au chu
sainte justine le virage au service à la
carte c'est faire en 2007
l'usagé commande directement de sa
chambre en choisissant parmi différents
menus classiques aujourd'hui c'est que
quoi qu'ils allaient comme choix on y
notait on le dit toujours à la blague
quand tu appelles on doit te servir à la
prochaine heure sinon c'est gratuit on
vous et moi c'est clair c'est gratuit
parce que c'est un passeur mais il
choisit ils nous demandent ce qu'ils
souhaitent manger et qu'une collation je
prends des numéros mieux dans notre
cuisine
le secret c'est le partiellement c'est
la mise en place donc la production de
masse de nos matières premières qui ont
bâti à la portion rapide donc seulement
que le riz basmati le carré de lentilles
à l'indienne le jus de pomme la portant
de melon bien oui parfait dans une
rencontre on merci
donc c'est ici qu'on reçoit les fonds
reposte allait recommander se passe donc
c'est le cuisinier qui par le val pour
la préparation du plateau alors on
commence avec la cipressa ça représente
combien de repas dans une journée en une
journée on it alentours de 360 plateau
on a une moyenne à peu près de 120
plateau par pas mis ce qui devient peu
plus difficile c'est nous recettes à
toute heure joe dante en 6 ans le matin
19 heures le soir l'enfant peut placer
sa commande donc des déjeuners on peut
en trouver à tort jo nous en 2016 on a
fait un virage
on avait un taux de satisfaction qui
était pas bon le premier taux de
satisfaction était à 50 % ensuite de sa
ont jeté 25% des plateaux donc il ya 25
points des plateaux qui revenait à la
cuisine on les met à la poubelle pour
toucher complètement oui le 25 pour
salon était directement la poubelle
donc on s'est mis à faire un balisage
pour essayer de comprendre qu'est ce qui
existait dans le marché qu'est ce qu'on
pouvait faire qu'est-ce qu'un hôpital
peuvent faire comme type de service pour
dépasser et le service aux charmes nous
est apparu comme étant la solution
[Musique]
en effet c'est après avoir pris
connaissance de l'existence du service
aux chambres dans d'autres hôpitaux
canadiens que josée lavoie il ya vu la
solution recherchée ce cas
sainte-justine souhaitais est d'amener
le contrôle au passé reconnaît
hospitalisé c'est un enfer compères
c'est bien contrôler le médecin décide
quand il veut nous voir on doit passer
des examens des prises à 100 dépression
peu importe ce qu'on réalisait sur toi
dans la visite et halifax
c'était que le patient et à la
possibilité de au moins décider de ce
qu'ils souhaitent manger
depuis l'implantation du système de
commande à la carte le taux de
satisfaction de la clientèle de sainte
justine est passé de 50 à 90 7 %
tu peux choisir ton aliment on te livre
au moment où tu as faim c'est humain
c'est bon pour le passé djoudi car y
travaillent dans cet hôpital de halifax
depuis 44 ans elle a donc vécu la
transformation du service alimentaire
ici qui a expiré josée lavoie de sainte
justine
[Musique]
les usagers de l'hôpital idol uk de
halifax peuvent commander 24 heures sur
24 des repas à la carte ou à débloquer
on a opté pour des plats simples même
certains produits transformés des fois
c'est plus important qu'ils mangent que
d'avoir trop de restrictions sur l'ordi
et puis on veut vraiment qu'ils
guérissent des fois ça prend un peu plus
de calories un peu plus de protéines
c'est pas toujours le moment de dire
moins de sel moins gras on veut
certainement promouvoir la santé
mais il faut aussi revoir la famille
puis la qualité de vie du patient
après son passage à l'hôpital hyde au
bouquet brenda mcdonald's a été nommé à
la tête des services alimentaires de la
régie de la santé de la nouvelle écosse
elle a implanté le tarif holding dans
dix autres établissements de la province
et ne compte pas s'arrêter là
[Musique]
qu'est ce que j'apprends
il y en a plusieurs qui viennent nous
visiter
mais je pense qu'ils font que
l'alimentation soit revue différents
[Musique]
il est 9h du matin au halifax infirmary
le service alimentaire de cet hôpital
fonctionne encore de manière
traditionnelle
les employés de la cuisine centrale
s'active donc à la préparation en
liaison froide des plateaux de repas qui
ne seront servis qu'à l'heure du souper
[Musique]
cette même cuisine approvisionne
d'autres hôpitaux et centres
d'hébergement de la région certains
repas sont donc préparé plusieurs jours
à l'avancé
[Musique]
forte du succès de son service à la
carte dans une dizaine d'hôpitaux
brenda va de l'avant avec un concept
encore plus novateur
chaque étage aura sa petite cuisine de
services permettant une réelle proximité
entre les chefs et les patients qui se
verront offrir des plats aussi frais et
variés qu'au restaurant
l'équipe de brenda mise également sur
les effets positifs pour les employés
sous sauter asiatique poulets grillés
poisson et le populaire mc n 6 des plats
maison qui vont rendre le séjour à
l'hôpital plus à gré c'est très bon ça
rien à voir avec la nourriture d'hôpital
à laquelle on est habitué à ces années
avec un mélange qui et qui contient pas
de sel mais c'est savoureux tout bon
très bon même si ça s'est même à la
limite c'est difficile à croire que
c'est de nourriture qui veut de sa vie
des patients moi je trouve bien bonne
nouvelle prestation
après plusieurs mois d'essais cette
nouvelle cuisine sera opérationnel d'ici
la fin de 2020 dans cet hôpital
l'objectif de brenda lodeiro dany ou des
cuisines aux étages art ou en nouvelle
écosse c'est beau c'est ce qu'on appelle
pour le moment la nôtre par les autres
partis bien nourrir le patient c'est
plus que jamais la façon de voir
l'alimentation dans les hôpitaux s'est
mise en marche il faut je pense qu'on va
le vendre comme le prouve un portique
avaient péri
le consensus se fait sur la saveur il
faut que ce soit bon si c'est purement
clinique à 100% clinique est conforme et
que c'est pas manger y compris ce qu'une
suppléments ni la nutritionniste ou
l'entretien unique ni moins n'auront été
un objectif
on veut que ça marche on veut que ça
s'améliore on veut que tu manges selon
la besoin on veut qu'il y ait une
rapidement à la base ce qu'on souhaite
c'est qu'ils mangent
alors je pense que ça en plus l'été les
bretelles parce que ces réussites nos
patients y mange on fait la cuisine pour
les gens que l'on connaît et que l'on
qu'on aime qui pourrait être notre mère
notre père la ligne qui nous sépare des
passionnés fois humains sont des fois on
passe du côté qu' on vit l'expérience
patients intéressant très intéressant
car ça t'arrive souhaite que ce soit un
fake afssa ce que c'est
[Musique]